[Music]
hey what's up you guys
it's sunday it's storming outside so
hopefully the power doesn't go out it
flashed off like a couple minutes ago
yeah and we we've uh had a little power
out of just here so we might lose the
internet connection yeah but i think
it's well it seems like it's it sounds
like it's going away for you know
because a few minutes ago i was just
kind of like holy [ __ ] and i'm
mysteriously coughing again out of
nowhere he's coughing yeah just this
[ __ ] dry [ __ ] that shirt looks
nice on you actually got this shirt
jenny bought this shirt for me last
night last night i got that and i got
this one who was the opening band
obsidian they were actually like quite
awesome the temple of mercy
it's the sisters of mercy tribute band
yeah they didn't look like sisters but
they sounded like it i don't know the
lead singer kind of looked like he kind
of looked like andrew elder and he had
like all of andrew eldridge's like moves
moves it down and stuff like
they covered the whole i i laughed
because they covered like the whole
stage with like
smoke and i was like oh we're getting
the whole sister some mercy experience
like we could barely see yeah and there
was no drummer
because mercy didn't have a drama i
thought that was so funny they they were
like we talked to them for a couple
minutes after they seemed like super
nice dudes but yeah they're having fun
it was a yeah that was a great show
actually we had a really good time
but uh yeah so today
well we have okay well let's talk about
the movie first and then
we're gonna talk about um just a couple
of like little housekeeping things which
are like not a big deal about some
some about a haunting and something
about the
topic for the show this week
so we'll get into that but first let's
talk about invaders from mars now you
had seen this before right long time ago
i had seen it once like a long time ago
yeah but i barely barely remembered it
yeah um i remembered it being like toby
hooper and i remember it being like
liking it and i remember like the
special effects being really cool like
the monster designs and stuff but that
was literally all i remember i i didn't
know anything about toba hooper or any
of that [ __ ] i just saw it like on
hbo or cinemax or something back when it
was relatively new
and saw it on old crt television and it
looked like crap you know
everything did on that yeah
and but i still liked it i thought it
was a great movie
and i didn't remember much about it i
just knew that it was a little kid
fighting martians
and that
it was
it was it i remember feeling like it was
a big budget movie
and i wasn't uh disappointed seeing it
again
it's a [ __ ] excellent movie uh
especially for the times like gremlins
or something and
about like that level of production
maybe less in terms of special effects
the acting and the writing is good it's
it's homaging the original which is a
50s sci-fi yeah in 1953 and it borrows a
lot
of stuff from the 50s and it
it's almost
it's very much reminded me of war of the
worlds the original war of the worlds
there's a lot of design in it it's like
something out of war of the worlds mixed
with invaders of mars from mars and
alien and
crazy [ __ ] aliens and weird
technology and
soldiers fighting it the the
actual soldiers they were marines
marine recon unit fighting it
and uh
yeah it was it was you know the
equipment was really accurate for the
time you know i had a good time seeing
that old equipment because
a few years later i was in the army with
a lot of that equipment it was being
phased out at the time i went in but a
lot of that [ __ ] was still in service
when i was in well yeah they actually
did get the uh after a while they did
actually get the cooperation of the us
marines so there are some actual marines
and like actual marine [ __ ] yeah it was
it was authentic it was all accurate
yeah and um one of the guys in there
yelling and screaming in the background
is a dude that ended up being real
famous he was in
he was in under siege
he he always downplayed general he still
plays a general i forgot that guy's name
i think he was even mustache yeah he's i
think he was like even the consultant
yeah he's always a military consultant
type guy
and he's in there he fires the m47
dragon goes back blast area clears
cheesy as [ __ ] it's like right out of
something out of basic training
something you would never really do in
[ __ ] real combat really but it's just
but the movie that's the tone of the
movie the tone of the movie is the 1950s
mars versus the
versus the marines that's the motif with
a little kid telling you the story
and then he wakes up in a solid dream
that's it even even left that [ __ ]
that kind but then it was a dream but
then it came true
yes that was some weird [ __ ]
but uh i didn't i i forgot i think the
original was he wakes up it's a dream
yeah i mean this is pretty much
i mean the um when they decided they
were gonna remake it
the original screenplay uh which was
written by richard blake
it was they used the original screenplay
but then like they reworked it like dan
o'bannon and uh don jacoby they they
reworked it but it's very very similar
there's a couple things in there that
are updated but they wanted to leave it
the same i think kind of that might have
been the reason because this movie was
actually kind of like a big flop um it
only cost 7 million to make and it made
less than 5 million back
i kind of feel like even though there
was a lot of 50s nostalgia and 50s
remakes and stuff like that going on in
the 80s
i think that
a lot of the remakes were made that were
like clearly 80s movies but this one
seems like yes it takes place in the 80s
but the tone of it was very much like
the 50s movie yeah and i think that
people really didn't like didn't get
that maybe yeah i don't know if you i
don't think that they knew that it was
an homage to an older movie maybe not
part of it
because i remember we were watching it
we were basically in our teens and we
didn't know there was another invader
from mars an older one so i think that
might have been part of it but i just
wanted to say if you guys can't hear it
man the whole [ __ ] world is ending
out there
chances are we're going to lose power
well i don't know like i said it sounds
like it's getting better because it was
much louder than that yeah it's like the
[ __ ] apocalypse
hey it's florida in the summer it does
this like pretty much everything yeah
you're doing right around this time
we're in the florida monsoon it's just
lightning and
like blowing against the window and [ __ ]
like that but so okay so
did you know this was uh this was canon
films you know that right
this is a [ __ ] excellent canon films
if it's canon i didn't know it was canon
yeah we'll see one of the best ones that
they've ever made well what ended up
happening i mean toby hooper obviously
like everybody that's under horror knows
toby hooper he's a very very famously
made texas chainsaw massacre like among
us he also did funhouse he did lots lots
of other stuff now
he actually had a three picture deal
with canon and the first one which came
out in 1985 was life force remember that
one like i love that movie actually
um but and that was kind of an also yeah
well yeah well canon they you know they
were known for doing like real low
budget stuff you know what i mean so
force was good life force was actually
their attempt at doing something like
big budget because you have to think
like toby hooper at this point he had
directed poltergeist right so he was
kind of like a big deal so like okay
well canon is trying to get like play
with the big boys right so they give
toby hooper like a whole bunch of money
they're like we want to make this book
and it was called space vampires and uh
so they made it into life force and it
was a giant giant flop it's ridiculous
because that was a movie we liked it
then yeah i mean basically
britain versus hot naked vampire chick
24 7. yeah i mean how can you how could
you not like
the mistake that they made was calling
it life force they should have they
showed an original
poster that they were going to use
remember it was like upside down crosses
flying towards the earth with vampires
inside of them it was
that would have been a better poster i
think it was called space vampires
wouldn't it well i mean that was the
name of the book so i don't think i
think that was the cover of the book
that i remembered that would have made a
good movie just call it space vampires
and had that naked chick on there and
yeah people people really don't see it
yeah maybe i don't know it's like that's
the thing but yeah life force is kind of
one of those ones that it did like
really badly at the time but you know
subsequently got a cult uh following
so
uh because that one kind of tanked uh
toby hooper still had two films to make
with canon
and this was actually the second one now
they had been wanting to
i guess like um golan and globus they
were big like sci-fi fans and they were
talking to this one guy that was a
really big fan of the original and
really wanted to see it like with a
bigger budget but because life force
kind of failed they're like well now
we're not going to give you like a big
huge budget for
this movie for invaders from mars so
they only gave them seven million
and so they remade it i mean this has
like giants karen black is in this the
kid did you know the kid that's in this
movie that plays like the main character
for one second that what that is sexy
ass karen black to you yeah remember
every time her every time that name is
mentioned it it's always
prefaced with sexy ass okay
okay okay anyway that's for the fans um
yeah the kid that's in the movie is her
actual son is it okay yeah um so yeah so
now i forgot what i was saying but um
yeah now you're now you threw me off my
[ __ ] nose why did you you need to
quit interrupting because it was funny
though it was funny because you keep
like uh throwing me off like mine okay
my train of thoughts feel okay but um
yeah so that was her real kid yeah karen
black is in this louise fletcher is in
this um
timothy bottoms is in this actually uh
louise fletcher eats a frog in it so and
then like when she did when she did no
it's not a real problem but like um when
she did the scene i think she made a
joke it's like i have an oscar what am i
doing like
eating a frog but you know she uh she
was pretty game though i like that she
just kind of went for it and was just
this was way over the top
yeah i mean i put it there with life the
thing about it it's like this kind of is
one of those movies that oh and lorraine
newman is in this too yeah that's right
i was going who is that woman and who is
that woman and then yeah you said
lorraine newman yeah that's not forever
from coneheads yeah she even does the
conehead's voice at the end
yeah like to the to the boy okay like
she does like alien voice and she does
like the connie cone head voice they
asked her to do it and she was like no i
don't want to do this i just remember
her from saturday night live being a kid
and she was on there yeah all the time
back when saturday live was good back in
the 70s and the 80s yeah
but yeah so this had like
a bunch of stars in it and honestly it's
the thing about it like life force was
obviously not for children right because
it's like a naked lady like going
through the whole thing and it was like
a horror movie and toby hooper was more
known even though he'd made poltergeist
you know him and steven spielberg and
that was kind of family friendly
although it was pretty scary
um this one was kind of i think it was
initially wanted to be like the same
kind of tone as boulders it's like sort
of
you know it's sort of uh geared toward
kids because a kid is the main character
like a 10 year old kid or however the
[ __ ] old he is um but it's still like
really scary i know that like a lot of
kids i've heard that a lot of kids that
saw this when they were that age like
the same age as the kid were scared by
this movie
like because it was suspenseful yeah and
the thing about area
yeah i mean it's not really scary it
might have been scary like in 1986 when
you were 10. i think the scariest thing
about it not so much the aliens although
i absolutely love like the alien designs
in this and um that was like stan
winston did the and john dykstra and uh
i think they look really really cool
like the the brain on the
thing and all that and the brain penis
yeah the brain penis or whatever
standing on a shad yes
it lays itself down on a pedestal like
it should and then you just like open
this little mouth yeah
he's like he's cool i think he's
cool-looking i liked the little face
that he had on there he had the nut sack
monsters yeah and then
walking around with backwards legs and
[ __ ] yeah that's pretty good the whole
reason that they made the monsters look
like that was because well we wanted to
do practical effects and we wanted like
aliens that looked like but they're like
we didn't want like a dude in like the
look of a dude in a rubber suit they're
like because that's the problem as you
always have so they wanted to like make
it so it was
didn't really look like a human i think
i don't know if they actually ended up
doing this but one of their original
ideas was they were gonna have like
bodybuilder guys like kind of walking
backwards with like little people like
on their backs like controlling the [ __ ]
so that might be how they have done that
you know what i mean because yeah but i
really really like the monster designs
in this as well
um it's all kind of me to me it was all
kind of light-hearted you weren't
supposed to take it seriously it was
just tongue-in-cheek good action
and
and a lot of it was homaging
yeah well a lot of it was homaging the
the original
um actually the guy that played the
original kid
actually had a cameo in this i think he
was like the chief of police or
something like he only has like a liar
too but they put him in it there's all
kind of little like sci-fi in jokes you
know what i mean like the references to
the earlier movie references to
um invasion of the body snatchers like
that kind of stuff so there's all that
kind of stuff in there and i kind of
feel like
i don't know you can tell that like toby
hooper and the producers and everything
like that were really really into the
original and we're really really happy
to
make it but i don't
i don't know i just think the time
wasn't right i think this is another one
that was really like appreciated
later on
although i do kind of feel like it's not
usually one that a lot of toby hooper
fans bring up
and i was kind of watching a bunch of
different
horror channels like reviews of it and
some of them really really dig it and
some of them are just kind of like eh
it's like not one of his best ones
but i don't know there's something like
actually really charming about it it's
not funny and it's not i don't know it
has it just has a very much like golly g
williker's like 50s kind of vibe to it
you know yeah but i th to me that works
and honestly the alien designs like the
creature designs the design of like the
inside of the ship like with all the
colored lights and like just all that is
so so cool yeah it's all colorful and to
me it was kind of thought i thought it
was homaging the uh the original
war of the worlds because it was it was
cut in color and but the colors kind of
looked
real artificial
and a lot of green lights inside coming
out of the and a lot of the technology
that they had was kind of like something
you'd see from war of the worlds it was
good yeah um you know they had drilling
apparatus with like lights and eyeballs
and [ __ ] blades on it and stuff kind
of made out of copper
and just they had nonsensical alien
technology that really didn't make much
sense but it was just cool you know like
a ray gun you could put a strip of
copper into it it would just send out
this amazing bolt
of [ __ ] lightning basically you know
and ions and it would vaporize yeah it
would just vape right but it only had
one shot yeah then you'd have to like
stick another yeah you could put another
one there it took two hours to operate
it
and which of course gives plenty of time
for the marines just to cut them cut
them to shreds with m60s and m16s and
rockets and stuff you know
the aliens didn't make much sense they
were in these tunnels you never really
saw the ship or maybe the ship was in
the center of the tunnels and they could
make the tunnels disappear and rearrange
which that was kind of a cool idea it
didn't make sense but that's like
something in the 50s in the 50s you know
they're teleporting the tunnels
or or
covering the tunnels up they got tunnel
control
you know something like that but it's
cool it's just it's just a
it's a 1950s style
sci-fi action adventure horror
and they've got to throw weird
technology at you alien technology
well and in the universe of the movie
you have to remember spoiler alert uh
it's all a dream it's all like a 10 year
old kid's dream yeah and if you look
he's
the the the little boy who's kind of the
main character of the center of the
story
everything's revolving around him he's a
kenny he's coming up with all the damn
no he's a total king he's a total kenny
he's coming
with all of the solutions he's saving
the marines and [ __ ] helping him get
out he goes to the general and like
ghost tells the general what to do
[ __ ] um he's saving his uh uh
school nurse who's
got to be his love interest she's
looking to him to what to do some of the
times you know i mean he's dude that's
his mom
it's not in a movie
that was that was the that was the nurse
he was crushing on yeah so he's
got a man up and save her you know it's
so it's it's kind of a good hearted
story
and in the end he wakes up and it was
all just a dream but then he looks out
the window and he sees the ship [ __ ]
landing
a dream it was a premonition
well i think and i can't remember like
how the original 1953 one ended because
it's been years and years since i've
seen it but this one i think people were
like a little bit like
i don't know like maybe disappointed or
like what like by the ending because
you know he wakes up it was all a dream
everything's back to normal and then
he's actually uh goes to his window and
sees the alien ship again like actually
landing this time just like in his dream
and then at the very end of the movie
like he runs into his parents room like
oh my god you guys it's like [ __ ] ufo
or whatever and then like he screams but
they don't show you
what it is that is screaming often like
they're and then it just freeze frames
and then they roll the credits now what
i heard i don't know if this is true or
not
i heard
that there was actually supposed to be
another scene
where he was seeing his parents being
eaten
by the ball bag aliens thank you yeah
the camp guy just called like the balls
that came up
um that they were like eating his
parents and that's what he was screaming
at but for whatever reason they either
didn't shoot it or you know they didn't
i don't know but that's what i heard i
don't know if that's true or not it was
a ball sack alien it looked like the
plant from little shop of [ __ ] had a
baby with the ball sack what it would
come that's what it looked like little
legs
i liked their bacon i liked their big
yeah i like their big like uh like you
said like the plants like audrey too
like yeah and then and then it and
they've been ended up on power rangers
it's like something out of power rangers
but it's cool though yeah it's not
you're not supposed to take this serious
seriously this turns out to be the a
kid's dream yeah
but still made a good action movie and i
mean i will go to bat for that like
brain penis alien because i think that's
cool without looking i think that's cool
as hell like he comes out the little the
little butthole he comes out the end
and lays his [ __ ] laces [ __ ] and
then comes down and he's directly down
the shaft comes down and lays the hood
on the [ __ ] thing that smiles at you
i like his eyes were cool i thought he
was like really freaky looking
i thought he was cool but what i was
gonna say before was that
as rad as the monsters are in this i
think if you were a little kid
i think the monsters probably aren't the
scariest part because the monsters are
kind of like just goofy and fun i think
the scariest thing about this for kids
at least from you know people that i had
heard that watch this when they were
kids was that it was more that everybody
like all the adults in your life had
like turned against you because they'd
all been taken over because you're
powerless yeah because if you don't know
like the whole premise of the story is
that you know the kid sees this alien
ship like land on this hill like behind
his house
and then like his dad who's like some
like a scientist right like he works for
nasa or some [ __ ] like that and he goes
back there to check it out and then he
comes back and he's all like weird what
year did this come out again 86
okay so i was 17. yeah
i remember i remember seeing it going oh
man that kid's [ __ ] you know oh that
would suck all the adults are now after
you you know what i mean what would you
do because you know i was i was young
enough to kind of feel for the kid in
that way you know mean because that's
when you're ten
adults can tell you what to do
even if they're the aliens and no one
would believe you no one would believe
you i mean because essentially what the
aliens are doing you find out later on
is that they're taking people inside the
ship putting them face down on this you
know kind of massage table deal and then
they're putting this thing in the back
of your neck that essentially like
controls your brain it's like a little
it's like a little like remote control
like spike or something and so kill you
through it yeah yeah if you disobey like
they'll blow your [ __ ] head up or
whatever so they've been doing that so
like then his dad comes back and then
his dad's acting all weird and then like
he's like hey i'm gonna take your mom
out for a picnic to the thing and he's
like yeah no i'm not gonna go and so
like they go and then they both come
back and they're both acting really
weird like they're eating like she's
eating like raw
hamburger with like sugar on it and he's
like eating all this there's a big pile
of bacon that's like burned to a crisp
and they're like crunching it like and
[ __ ] like that and he's just like and
then like a couple of the like louise
fletcher's uh character uh she's like a
teacher at school who's
a complete herodon
and she gets taken over and then like
the other little goody two-shoes girl at
school she gets taken over and he
doesn't really have anybody to turn to
because
you know he has to look at the back of
everybody's neck because you can see
like where they inserted the little
thing in there so he basically runs to
sexy ass karen black there you go who's
yeah who's like the school nurse because
she's like nice to him and
you know
so she so he tells her about the story
and she obviously doesn't believe him at
first but then you know [ __ ] happens and
then like she starts to believe him so
then like he ends up having to like go
to the general and they like figure out
what's going on but yeah there's a lot
of mars attacks in this too yeah um and
if you go i think some of it was taken
from the source material of mars attacks
mars attacks that idea came from a bunch
of trading cards they were from the 50s
i think weren't they the trading cards
yes and i think so they i think they
were i think i think those trading cards
might have been called mars attacks yeah
it's a bunch of trading cards that kids
could buy we used to buy trading cards
too like [ __ ]
monsters that were football players and
baseball players and [ __ ] well they had
those back in the 50s and it was a
series
of gruesome [ __ ] cards they were very
gruesome [ __ ] i loved them i can
understand yeah the art's amazing yeah
you can you can google them and look at
them mars attacks trading cards and
they're just this [ __ ] gruesome [ __ ]
and just let you know how
different the world was it was
i was still kind of growing up in the
70s it was still like this a bit
it's drawings of aliens busting through
into little girls rooms and cooking the
cat right in front of her with a damn
ray gun and she's screaming and the
cat's [ __ ] half burnt up and [ __ ]
with it
and then you know them just burning
people up it's just like right out of
mars attacks
but it wasn't funny
it was
like it was like something out of world
war ii it's exactly what it was it was
it was what we were doing to the
japanese soldiers and the germans but it
reversed imagine if aliens doing that to
americans
cooking the cows and cows stampedes and
they're cooking them with [ __ ] ray
guns and
burning up little girls with ray guns
and [ __ ] [ __ ] quite impressive
drawings uh
and real cool symbols and everything is
from the alien point of view like this
is all great
you know there's symbols on it like like
these cards came from mars what it
looked like that's how my interpretation
of it they were martian trading cards
kind of
exalting their
triumph over mankind and the destruction
of mankind and it's just that was alien
[ __ ] man and [ __ ] little kids were in
the 50s were collecting these
and it just lets you know [ __ ]
what way society was you know
and i think even although i heard that
some of the parents even in the 50s
didn't like those cards they thought
they were too violent yeah yeah there
was a huge outcry well we talked about
that when we talked about the movie mars
attacks yes but those cards
the colors and certain the ways that
definitely that definitely inspired the
mars attacks movie but i also see that
in this some of the things that
that they drew the color schemes looks
like they came from those cards
um
were influenced by it mixed with alien
and other stuff there's a mixture of a
bunch of stuff but i think those cards
had something to do with it too you know
remember the outside scenes where the
ships
are landing that's definitely in a
studio that's right off of those cards
yeah well a lot of the stuff from the
movie was right off of the cards like
the cows on fire and all that kind of
stuff what i'm talking about in this in
this one uh
vader's from mars some of that also
looks like those mars of tax cards
yeah yeah
slasher fred said uh invaders for mars
is sort of like pre-invasion of the body
snatchers yeah it's kind of similar i
mean the invasion of body center was
based on a novel didn't
yeah
right but yeah well there was another
movie too what the [ __ ] was the name of
it um i think beverly garland was in it
i saw it in mystery science theater
and it had a very similar premise to
this was it it conquered the world it
was the one with the space carrot or
zucchini or whatever you know what i'm
talking about it's like roger corman you
know the one that lived in the cage cave
and like kind of looked like a vegetable
yeah i think um well the mouth yeah well
see that had another like kind of side
plot that he was like sending out like
from underneath his little
from his little skirt or whatever like
underneath his little feet
um he would send out these little bat
creatures and the bat creatures would
kind of like
stick on the back of your neck and would
do like control your thoughts like in
this one
so there was a lot of that kind of stuff
going on in the 50s like this sort of
like aliens doing mind control you know
so like yeah invasion of the body
snatchers all that but yeah there was
another like roger corman one that had
the same kind of thing with but it was
bad creatures that did it
so that's this is kind of like another
one like that
hugo said the mars attacks card that
upset people was the one with the
martian grabbing a white lady
[Laughter]
yeah well they were doing [ __ ] it was
all white people
but that was just
it was like war propaganda world war ii
war propaganda which looked like that
too
you know
japanese soldiers grabbing white women
that was like one of the war propaganda
stuff that was happening in certain
areas um not in the united states but
over in uh
when they occupied the philippines they
captured a bunch of i think they were uh
british women and forced them into
servitude what they called it
um but that's all
there but they turned that into a
propaganda arm so it was
those cards are just right out of
[ __ ] world war ii it's like imagine
if
martians made
trading cards about their war against us
and it looks like
just shows you what the psychology's
like you know of that era
and
well i mean that seems to me like a very
modern idea like if somebody did that
nowadays like made and like if it hadn't
been done back then but somebody said oh
i'm going to pretend like i'm an alien
race and i'm going to make these things
like where it looks like i'm [ __ ] up
all the humans yeah then people would
think it was like really awesome yeah so
it's like it was almost kind of like
ahead of its time and well
and i think that the those trading cards
were actually some of the first if not
the first that were like not based on an
existing like
yeah yeah they were just they were
completely original they weren't from a
cartoon or like a tv show or nothing
like that my interpretation is that they
were the trading cards being traded on
mars celebrating the martian victory
over earth yeah that's that's it
that [ __ ] are cruel man like
something out of world war ii yeah yeah
pretty cool but yeah so this movie
invaders from mars like i said it really
seems to have like mixed response even
to this day i think rotten tomatoes it's
still like 38
um like i said i've seen like some
horror fans that were like really really
dig it and think it's like really
underrated and then someone was like
well
i just i don't think anybody thinks it's
like awful but some people are just kind
of like they don't think it's that great
but
i actually really like it there's just
something about the tone of it that i
really got into like i said you kind of
have to watch it even though it's said
in the 80s you have to watch it as
though it's like a 50s movie because
it's very much like totally like a 50s
movie interestingly at the time that it
came out
this was nominated for
two
razzies
uh louise fletcher for worst actress
ridiculous
she has an oscar leave her alone and
worst visual effects that makes
absolutely no sense to me whatsoever
because the visual effects in this are
actually quite awesome like all the
movie all the all the creatures like
look amazing all the set design is
amazing so whatever i don't know man the
razzies
they they come up with some stupid [ __ ]
but yeah so do you have anything else to
say about the movie because i have a
couple of um okay uh one thing to say
about the movies people are saying i
can't imagine like an alien an alien
civilization traveling light years to
come and [ __ ] over somebody else yeah
but ants can't imagine a bunch of
rednecks running around on four-wheelers
either
you know
there's a lot of things that are beyond
our imagination
um there are some very reputable
biologists and scientists and stuff that
said no there probably is danger in in
the uh in the galaxy
and uh they wouldn't come for water or
anything like that it would be
something else
like they just might go those are good
to eat let's go eat those
because they would just see you as an
animal that's what i mean we could just
be like we could just be like
intergalactic snacks or something yeah
or they're like little party shrimp of
the universe they're biological but
they're one of one of the most uh common
biological reproductive plan in nature
is like what the wasps do they're like a
parasite they sting you immobilize you
lay an egg in you and then you feed
their young that's a very common
reproductive plan
there's no reason why
advanced aliens
couldn't be like that and make
technology and not give a [ __ ]
well the thing about it too is that even
on earth we have humans who just do
you know ass holy [ __ ] just for the hell
of it so i you know i i don't think it's
that crazy to think that there's
probably some aliens that are probably
just
interplanetary [ __ ] yeah and you
just want to go around just being jerks
there's no reason why they would be
enlightened
in the way that we would think
enlightened they're no reason to think
that they that they have such a short
lifespan where being in space for a few
million years of sleep that might not be
a big deal for them
good so they don't have the same concept
of time
or they might just be where they can
just bend space and just teleport across
vast distances that might be possible
too through wormholing and stuff
and using technologies that we can't
imagine
we would see it as
magic and they wouldn't need anything
other than having something to do with
food or reproduction so they wouldn't
want our technology or anything the only
thing we would probably have that they
would think would be interesting maybe
art
like oh wow could we collect art from
other cultures and stuff
because you know it's like that it comes
from that tribe only they make that you
know
that would probably be the only thing
unique about us
but they would just use it as a trophy
slasher fred said the twist plot of it
being a dream is very similar to a movie
called robot monster yeah that's right
the one with the uh alien and the
gorilla suit and the diving helmet that
was also a little boy's dream and then
danny rowling says the dream plot twist
is never a good look for tv or film in
my opinion i can't stand that twist yeah
honestly um it's just it's usually very
lazy the only reason i think it works in
this case is that one you know it's
homaging the original which had the same
ending and two you're led to believe
that it wasn't so much just a dream as
like a premonition you know what i mean
like he because he sees actually after
he wakes up from the dream he actually
does see the the thing so you're led to
believe that it's gonna happen now when
he just saw it ahead but yeah so that's
why
but
okay so
what was i gonna i would have like a
couple of like little talk about she
were to change certain things about the
show i mean not changing stuff like that
really but like well adding or changing
again it's not that big a deal don't get
don't get excited uh the first thing i
want to do if you're not on our patreon
i did a really stupid thing you know how
i do
the patreon polls like to pick a topic
for the next week okay well the topic
that won for this week like this coming
wednesday was the james rupper easter
sunday massacre and haunting
and so i was like okay that one i
started like doing notes for it and then
i was like wait this case sounds like
really familiar so i looked into our
back catalog and we've already done a
show about that and it wasn't even that
long ago it was like episode 253 or
something i'm like oh my god i am the
stupidest person alive um or the most
disorganized you know it could be that
so i was like all right well obviously
we can't do that show again because we
just did one on that like not too long
ago so what i did was i went with the
next topic that had the next like
number of votes which was actually the
british premonitions
bureau
which actually i just heard about
on that show with uh unexplained with um
william shatner so we'll do a show about
that instead another thing we were just
talking about like literally right
before we started streaming was
and a lot of you guys have wanted us to
go back to doing like some reviews of a
haunting episodes and there's like a
whole bunch that we still want to do i
think we've talked about this before
what we decided to do because i keep
putting them like in the polls but they
usually don't win
so i was like well why don't we do
like maybe once a week like
instead of doing a movie for the matinee
we'll do a haunting episode for the
matinee like so we'll just do like one a
week like on sunday or monday or some
[ __ ] like that um so then that way we'll
be able to like work through all of them
without having to worry about them
winning in the polls or anything like
that and in a way it'll kind of be
easier for us because
they're shorter than movies and we don't
have to like keep finding movies and
stuff we're still going to do movies on
the other matinee days but just one
morning but just one day a week like on
one of the matinees uh we'll do a
haunting episode instead so i'm gonna
try i gotta go and like look at all the
ones we've done so i don't repeat any
but
i mean we've done like several but
there's still like a [ __ ] done that we
haven't done we got we got [ __ ] nine
seasons of that i think
yeah well i think well i think you we
have seven seasons because i think that
i gave you a couple more yeah there are
actually a few more i think there are
maybe 12 or 13 seasons all together yeah
i have to look i think i have most of
them i know i have most of the seasons
well i know that i think some of them
you can't get on dvd
yeah well after season seven or eight i
think they just stopped offering them um
because you can probably you can stream
them somewhere and who knows about the
quality we haven't checked because the
quad that that franchise got purchased
a couple of times and each time it got
purchased by new company the
quality kind of suffered the first
company was the best
yeah that has all the real classic
episodes on it so that's probably what
we'll do so probably like tonight we'll
pick out like an episode that we haven't
uh that we haven't covered and then
maybe we'll talk about that on the
matinee tomorrow and then get back to
movies like the next day because i just
wanted to like cover more of those
because i know a lot of people keep like
asking about them and i kind of want to
get back to doing them too because
that's kind of like we started out like
on the show like doing a lot of those
early on a lot of people seem to enjoy
those and they're fun so you know
um danny rowling said i suggested the
easter day massacre yeah i
it's weird because i have like this big
long list of topics and usually once we
once we do a show about it like i'll
take it off the list obviously but that
was still on there like to put into
polls and i don't know why it was still
on there i just forgot to delete it but
we have absolutely already done a show
about that because as soon as i started
reading about the case i was like oh
this looks like really familiar and then
like i looked back and i was like holy
crap it wasn't even that long ago that
we did that [ __ ] show but yeah uh
haunting in connecticut
did we do uh didn't we do an episode on
haunting in connecticut
i i don't know i kind of feel like we
did i'm gonna check one i don't remember
which one that is i'm gonna check
afterward and see which ones we've done
and then i get confused about what the
names of those episodes are that's the
only thing like the episodes of a
haunting they always have these really
generic titles right so they all kind of
the titles kind of blurred together like
dark destiny yeah i'm like
which one is that yeah
gotta go and look at them and go i
remember that one yeah and i'll remember
everything about it i just forgot what
the name of it was yeah because they all
have names like that yeah unless like
every now and then they'll do like a
haunting in florida or right or they'll
if it'll be like summer wind stands out
yeah because that's actually the name of
the place but then like most of them
just have these kind of like really
generic
like sinister intentions i'm like you're
not helping desire yeah you're not this
is porn
[Laughter]
it's red shoe diaries yeah but yeah it's
just you know so i so i have to keep
looking and i'm just like wait which one
is that i don't remember what that is
because it's like a dark shadows in the
hall
yeah it's always like dark something
yeah
yeah i think actually i think there is
lurks evil within evil above evil inside
evil beside
evil over there
yeah you do that [ __ ] all day long
we should just like make up well that
would be a fun show just to make up a
whole like list
that could actually be real episodes oh
my god
that's that's the most generic i'm
pretty sure that there is one call
i'm pretty sure there is one called that
but yeah so yeah so tomorrow we'll
probably do like a haunted episode
because like i said a lot of people seem
to like those and we like doing those as
well so uh yeah i guess we're gonna wrap
it up we're gonna wrap it up all right
so we will see you guys again
uh tomorrow evening have a good rest of
your weekend
and we'll see you later
bye